which player did you regret not signing
the most certainly cristiano ronaldo wow
i thought it was possible
and if we had been a fraction quicker
a few days because we had the grid and
man united came in five six days later
so i would say at the start of my career
uh
cristiano ronaldo at the end of my
career and guru county
hi everybody how you doing i'm ian
wright and i'll be putting the sport
bible fan questions to the bus and we're
here promoting the new film arsene
wenger invincible unfortunately i wasn't
there but i am invincible as well
so boss you ready yeah you relaxed you
chilled i'm i'm sleeping slowly
okay the first question was who was the
best signing you made
throughout your career we start very
different very starting this is what
they asked us this is what they are
no i made a few good signings
and uh maybe the best i i wouldn't say
the best but the the the signing
who gave me credit because i arrived the
same together with him was patrick's
beer
after you know of course people say
terry hungry
but
of course chariot as well was an
unbelievable signing but i came here
unknown yes and patrick
as i said uh many times people thought
we don't know this guy but at least he
brings good players but that's the thing
it's cause when when you came but people
were saying are saying who arson who and
then when patrick started to play like
you mentioned
then they say well it doesn't matter
because he knows what he's doing
that guy
i gotta say if i'm gonna be totally
honest
um
for me
seeing nicolas inelka
when he came and started training with
us boss makes you realize
your time is short
because i've never seen you it's funny
you say that because i had just i had
the lunch with rio ferdinand yesterday
and he said you asked and you asked and
you said you had good teams but the guy
who impressed me the most is nicholas
so nicholas i said i couldn't get up
with him on the first 10 yards and
that's why when i saw him last night
scoring the goals of arsenal
i thought i came too late for you
to get the best of you and it's true
that after you face a guy like america
it's difficult it's very difficult it's
very difficult okay next question is
which player did you regret not signing
the most
certainly cristiano ronaldo wow
i thought it was possible
and if we had been a fraction quicker
a few days because we had the grid and
main united came in five six days later
so i would say the start of my career
uh
cristiano ronaldo at the end of my
career and guru canter
you could have got kante as well yeah
easy because he played
in a club in paris yes that's called
siren where my one of my best friends is
director and he told me please
i have a player you know it's
unbelievable nobody wants him in france
he took him in his car
and
traveled with him
from club to club and finally a club of
division three in france took and guru
county wow
it is unbelievable story and guru county
you you could make a film as well with
him wow amazing angola can he ask would
have been amazing and he is he has
something that
you don't find often no
he wins the ball
without making any foul no
and straight away he moves that ball
forward he's very underrated in the way
he progresses as well very underrated
okay what's the next question is who was
the most underrated player
you coached
giberto silva is it
what was it about your birthday
he was naturally discreet
you know
and
i remember when i bought him in 2002
he
was in japan at the world cup and i
looked
at him i thought
you look
he doesn't make anything special
and to think who did win this ball ah
with who played visible audrey bertosia
and i tried
to buy him and after that
i would say he was
in the invincible nobody speaks about
jesus no no no
but he's a kind of uh player
you see only how much you miss them when
they don't play
when you play you find it all natural
and
olivier giroud was a bit like that in
the other way that means
when he missed the pass it was always a
clumsy part you know
but when you didn't play him you missed
some presents up front
it was a bit similar in a different way
but gilberto silva thought
he was lorraine as well he was a real
fighter of the old times yes
yes you know i was going to say to you
boss i'm hearing the story about colo
colatore and
when he was on trial
dude everybody
starting with me did he tackle you as
well how did he talk to you was he
playing or was he just going over he's
playing sometimes you know but uh color
i test i i played him against the
tablaridis at the time in training he
had such an enthusiasm color is a
similar story to angola county because
he was on trial
in strasbourg he was on trial in
anderlecht he was on trial in
basel
buzzer
nobody kept him
and
the guy who called me with him i knew
color because he was in our school
in ivory coast and i said look bring him
here before he flies back
to ivory coast and
i signed him of course because he had
such an enthusiasm and
hunger to be successful that's what we
talked about the defense last night yes
this defense cost zero
unbelievable from lehman loren
a soul camp who came for free and as
they called was it the club
lehman was
less than two million sold sold nothing
lowering 4 million euros
and so you had the back five
it didn't cost five million pounds
unbelievable
okay so boss next question is which loss
hurt you the most which lost when you
lost which one was it that made you feel
real
championship finally lost because
it would have been
all done you know and so it's a bit
unfinished job
the fact that we didn't win the
champions league and
especially
i would say the whole season we didn't
consider goal
in any qualifier we played real madrid
you went tooth
and
at the end of the day we go in the final
and
we play with 10 men so if you go you
think all that way for that you know i
know and
on top of that that makes the regret
even bigger we still should have won i
know we could have i remember terry
talking about
he felt very tired towards the end he
said he had no power left maybe because
he made
a fantastic game said real madrid
yes and
maybe he was tired yes you think he was
the best player in the world yes
i think i heard you mention him that he
could be michael jordan of football yes
he had everything unbelievable it's
funny because there was times you'd
watch arsenal
um and then we're getting in a game and
people are holding us out and then
thierry would have
like five ten minutes of his best and
the game is over
yeah
over when you got angry yes you know
the gameboy was craft of the neck and
you had that permanent digression you
know couldn't get i couldn't turn it off
you couldn't turn it off terry theories
was if you got him angry then he'd turn
his one up mine was always turned up
yeah unfortunately yeah no not
unfortunately i think it's a quality up
front you know you have a reputation for
finding hidden gems are there any hidden
gems out there that arsenal should be
signing
i feel uh
holland for example you know
holland
there's nothing hidden about him
of course god said he's a spurs fan
do you remember harry kane in the
arsenal academy at all no not at all no
he was at nine years of age you know
and uh
nine years of age who is good and not
good so if you have a chance to see them
but i didn't even know that he played
for us
and
so now
after he moved at 11 years of age
already to tottenham so it was too early
for me to know him and we're sorry we've
got spurs founder correct
but michael arteta played for you um
could you see him
becoming a coach yes i made him captain
um you know so i thought he would be a
coach yes because he had the passion for
the game he had the kind of
personality you know authority natural
authority
and
i didn't know would he be a manager you
know because between some people like
coaching but not necessarily taking all
the rest
i'm not surprised
i mean i must say uh
ian
from the first generation
the dickson you know
adams ball the winnebago
because there have been coaches or
managers yeah
it's true they were so organized they
were organized with strong personalities
you know
edu becoming um like a technical
director
um being in charge is that something you
would have seen and the way he played
because he's a very intelligent player
could you see him in this role what he
has now asked no not necessarily because
he was
an intelligent player like you said and
uh
i've worked
never thinking of a technical director
dustin from club because i thought it
was the role of the manager but now it
has been split
it's maybe not bad because
when you had
my role for example
in a modern game is too much you know
and as well maybe the club depends too
much on one person and
so it's a bit more divided today on
short term
the guy who coaches the team and the
long-term vision the guy who makes a
decision for
the next 10 years so
it's the evolution of it
i as long as the two have a good
understanding yeah it's not a problem
yeah but there's a time where um there's
so much speculation of the amount of
clubs
that wanted you to to to sign for them
real madrid maybe three times i don't
know what the national team when they
came was there any time
in and around
let's say 2007 onwards that you're
thinking maybe
maybe with the clubs because the caliber
of clubs they're talking real madrid a
few times was
madrid you went to paris and germa
two or three times you know i had all
these opportunities and the french
national team the english national team
and
basically
i was
happy at the club and
as well involved in paying the stadium
back you know yes i pushed the club to
build this stadium
after to walk away i was for me a little
bit
tricky you know
after
when we built the stadium they wanted me
to sign for five years to have a
technical guarantee the right
sustainability
so they used you as collateral
for that for the use me yes to give the
stability to and the guarantee to pay
the stadium back after earth
did you feel pressure was that was there
did you feel pressure with that that's a
lot of pressure i've never heard that
before i thought i thought
i didn't feel under pressure i just felt
it's natural
if we because we started to build the
stadium at 200 million we finished at
428 something like that wow so
uh
i pushed the club to do this monstrous
thing and i thought i have to give
something back you know and
when they asked me to sign for five
years i said okay let's go for it so uh
already i was there already uh
uh in 2006
10 years basically
so it pushed me 15.
in the middle of these five
i didn't see
walking away no
so after that
i extended again and suddenly make 22
years i don't know how and why
but what what trophy or title meant the
most to you
in your coaching career which was uh
undoubtedly 98 was the best
because it was the first time we won
and
i arrived unknown so to be
to be capable to win
and
i think that was the most meaningful
trophies and that's the day i realized
as well uh when you went through the
streets
there was a passion for the club
is that the first time you you saw that
because the open top bus yes i knew we
had always 38 000 people at highbury but
when you have 250 thousand in the street
you know how can you see that in a
different state i know how did 98
compare to the invincible season well
the invincible season was for me
the achievement of
the perfect season you know because in
our job you never know how good you are
because you know i think even if you win
the championship maybe somebody else
would have made more points
and
one more game so i was thinking always
to do the job well you have to be
do a season without losing a game when i
came out with that of course i was
hammered
england
england dining and they didn't like that
because it looked arrogant but on the
other hand you know you're always in the
court
or you play it safe
and you minimize your ambition or you
come out with your ambition and you look
arrogant but
somewhere
you have to set targets who are very
high for people because most of us
we like to do what is easy
and not what is difficult so
if we don't have high targets we get
slowly
in the comfort zone and that's why i
found that
and basically sometimes i thought myself
you are completely crazy
but it's not achievable but today
i i said i discovered you can play with
a do this job without fear to lose
and that the players raced above the ego
and just wanted to be dedicated and be
as good as they could be and enjoy the
next challenge
it was a happy group because we had no
no pain from losing games yes
and that just welcomed the next
challenge you know listening to thierry
sometimes he said that there was times
where they were very nervous going into
game especially that liverpool game yes
i was nervous watching this liverpool
game especially the way we started
so we get to a stage now and we're asked
it's happening and only a few games left
what was it like in the dressing room
then was you still talking about winning
this game or was anything to do with the
liverpool game yes but half time so the
whole team was shocked because we just
have been knocked out by chelsea yes of
course yeah
the whole team was shot
and i thought
the damage is much bigger than i thought
you know
and uh how can i get them so i try to
shake them up a little bit and then
in our job it's like that you need a
special player who does something
special
and i don't know why terry suddenly
turned up with something exceptional
but only the big players can do that and
they that's why
i say many times you know that
what is a big manager and manager speak
players
because they turn up
when you're under pressure when you need
them
and they deliver which manager did you
least enjoy going toe to toe with on the
sideline well i i never felt it's funny
that i never felt i played against the
manager i always felt i played against
the team right and
of course i had bad relations with
mourinho i had bad relations sometimes
his ferguson after we became
very very uh comfortable in our
relationship i had even with alan pardue
problems
you see with alan pardew boss was it
just because he was very disrespectful
i don't really remember i don't want to
accuse him of i was not an angel as well
you know so
what what
was marvelous i discovered peace when
you build a new stadium in the emirates
the benches are much farther much
further away and that suddenly you had
no problems anymore
you don't hear anymore what don't the
people say yeah and and boss before we
go i gotta ask you the last question um
would you ever
return to management um i would say
spontaneously i would say no
because i not even international
international maybe you know in a short
period why not but
i would like to
to still help club club might invest in
a club you know to be advised yes and uh
but
i don't want to make one fight too many
because at the end
people you know who could be your age
you say he's too old
and it's a bit age discrimination yes
especially when you go through a bad
period but overall uh
i did
1235 games wow
uh it's not bad it's not bad at all and
overall i think in my career i did over
2000 games maybe uh that i win two ten
more games or 20 more games will not
change my life now
i think i'm proud of more of what i want
of the values that you generate that you
have time to work on the longer distance
in the club
and today when i travel
i see many people who love arsenal for
other reasons than just winning the
premiership
is uh
because the club had a certain
desire to act with class and give
chances to young players from all over
the world you know and that is for me
more important i'm now involved in
giving every talent a chance in the
world and i would like to to to say
today in the world
it depends where you're born you know
if you're a young talented boy if you're
born in namibia in hanoi or in london
you have not the same chance to become a
player
and so i'm involved in a program
who
develops for help
especially for younger generations
all over the world
that was fantastic because you are ian
thank you boss i'll see you in a sec
united's travel winning team was better
than the invincibles
i'm still going to go invincibles
because it's never
ever been done
right and it's not been done since
despite you know city spending billions